we knew it was a possibility the raiders
could have a tough time against the
atlanta falcons after all
they get paid to play too as for this 7
37
point lost game film las vegas is going
to look at it like the forgotten moldy
casserole in the back of the
refrigerator
and throw it away john gruden and the
raiders were six and four through ten
games last year
really feel like this team is built to
respond to adversity better than last
year
hold that point derek carr under duress
as he was all game he is sacked
and fumbles the falcons recover atlanta
in giveaway mode
early on as well matt ryan intercepted
by jonathan abram
good bounce back for him his first pick
of the season derek carr builds on that
momentum with a dazzling ball
down the sideline to henry ruggs the
rookie what a play las vegas in business
the offense couldn't score daniel
carlson though he converts
it's a 6-3 atlanta lead early falcons
driving late in the second quarter
matt ryan to calvin ridley and he
celebrates by
throwing dice like he's at the el cortez
that's how we celebrate come on
raiders turn doesn't last long right
tackle brandon parker gets beaten by the
pass rush badly
carr is mauled atlanta recovers on the
sack fumble
third quarter fresh start right moldy
result interception by all pro
dion jones welcome to atlanta
touchdown nobody in sight
and they kept on stepping on the wounded
matt ryan to brandon powell
on a well-designed crossing pattern it's
a 30-6
game and it gets worse derek carr
he's going to be looking over his
shoulder for the rest of the week sacked
and stripped for the third time this
game
raiders had five turnovers the three and
seven falcons looked like the 1985 bears
43-6
las vegas gets jumped in georgia
there's some things you got to fight
through but you know when when we got
hit in the mouth i think with the fourth
and one the stop
uh then we fumble the next play we've
got to get up off the mat
and fight bet back better as a coaching
staff and as
a football team and that's something we
got to take a look at
like i said it's a reflection of me and
i apologize to the raider fans i didn't
think uh
personally we had our best week of
practice personally thought we were a
little flat
clearly that was the case in the game
and uh
anytime you turn the ball over like that
you're not you're not gonna win football
games
you know it's very rare uh percentages
are really low so
um yeah that they haven't felt this way
in a while so it's uh
it's a gut punch uh for sure i'll
apologize fans
well that's not who we are you know
that's not what we want to put on film
you know especially coming off a you
know heartbreaking loss like we did last
week
you know we were supposed to come out
here this weekend you know kind of take
our anger out on on falcons and i kind
of feel like we didn't do that i kind of
felt like we had a pity party for
ourselves